[inaudible]
what if our moon had a
twin seeing not just one,
but two of these satellites in the
night sky might be spectacular,
but how would the second moon
affects the ocean? Tides?
Would months on earth become longer or
shorter and would these two satellites
inevitably collide to
cause a massive explosion?
This is what if, and here's what would
happen if the earth had two moons,
despite what you think the earth isn't
really the monogamous type along with the
moon earth has another
moonlight companion, a small
asteroid wandering around it,
but it's so far and so small that it can
only be considered a quasi I satellite
to our planet.
In our scenario,
we're talking to real moons just like the
earth had during its formative period.
Yup. We likely had two satellites once
both of them formed when a Marseilles
protoplanet slammed into earth
and shattered into small pieces.
So what exactly would happen if the
earth had another moon parked in orbit
around it?
Let's assume our second moon would be
around 1000 kilometers wide and about one
30th the mass of our current moon,
it would be about the same distance from
Earth to just like the sister satellite.
Our Moon had four and a
half billion years ago.
Would we see this devil moon from earth?
Absolutely.
The second moon would just appear
about three times smaller. Still,
it would be a spectacular view along
with two moons would come some big tides.
The newly captured moon would have a much
smaller tidal effect than that of our
moon,
but the tidal force from both satellites
combined would make waves literally,
although those waves would be bigger,
they wouldn't be devastatingly big.
In the end,
I think surfers will be pretty happy.
The second moon might stay in Earth's
orbit for tens of millions of years until
eventually as the moon retreated
further from the earth,
it would destabilize
the other moon's orbit.
Then just like they did
over 4 billion years ago,
the two satellites would collide in slow
motion because they'd be moving slowly
towards each other. The debris from the
collision wouldn't shower back on earth.
The small moon would splatter itself
across our moon as an extra layer of solid
crust.
The new mountains of crushed rock visible
from the near side of our moon would
be the only reminders of its existence.
Now,
what if the second satellite happened
to be the same size as the moon and
orbited the earth at
half the lunar distance?
This time things wouldn't be so pretty.
The second moon alone would produce tides
eight times greater than what we see
right now that would force people away
from the coastal areas because the
difference between high and low tides
would now reach 300 meters constant tidal
flooding,
which shrink the habitable area on earth.
But once we adapted to this new world,
we'd get to enjoy a beautiful
double moon this time.
The second satellite would look bigger
from Earth due to its closer orbit.
The moons would also
have different phases,
which means we'd have to come up with
another way to measure a month and then
there's some worse news.
The two moons would be slowly moving away
from earth and eventually would crash
into each other. This collision
would send debris back to earth.
It would be a shower of media
rights of epic proportion,
and it could wipe us out entirely.
Whatever debris didn't fall to earth
would form yet another new moon in Earth's
orbit.
At that point,
a new post human life form may begin
to evolve and become earth's next
civilization, but that's a
story for another. What if.